نبدا هذا اليوم بمستجدات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث نقلت وكاله تاس عن جهاز
الامن الفيدرالي الروسي انه تم احباط هجوم
على خط السكك الحديديه في شبه جزيره القرم
من جهتها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
احباط هجوم اوكراني بمسيرتي على منطقه
بريانسك الروسيه وقالت الوزاره ان
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت احدى الطائرتين
المسيرتين بينما اعلن حاكم المنطقه
الكسندر بوجوز اسقاط المسيره الاخرى عند
اقترابها من منطقه بجنو فيتسكي اوضح ان
الهجوم لم يسفر عن سقوط ضحايا او احداث
خسائر
ماديه من جهتها افادت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان الدفاعات الاوكرانيه تصدت ل
16 مسيره فوق اوديسا كما افادت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان الجيش حقق تقدما
جنوب روبوتي وبخمس وانه يواصل التقدم على
جبهه زبروجيا جنوبا باتجاه ميليتوبول
وقالت الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها قصفت
مدينه بيرديانسك الواقعه على حوض بحر ازوف
التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه هذا
واوضحت الهيئه ان القوات الاوكرانيه خاضت
39 اشتباكا مسلحا على جبهات القتال
المختلفه في الساعات ال4
الماضيه وقالت خدمه الطوارئ الاوكرانيه ان
شرطيا قتل او قتل واصيب نحو 25 شخصا نتيجه
سقوط صخ روسي على مدينه كريفي واضافت
الخدمه ان شخصين اصيب على الاقل بجروح في
هجوم صاروخي روسي استهدف مدينه سومي شمالي
اوكرانيا في مقاطعه زبروجيا اصيب شخص جراء
سقوط صاروخ روسي بالستي على احدى
[موسيقى]
المنشات معنا من زورج مراس ال الزيره
الياس كرام ومن موسكو مراسل الجزيره نور
الدين الدغير ابدا معك نور الدين وتفاصيل
اكثر حول هذا الهجوم على سكه الحديد في
القرم نعم سهام هي محاوله هجوم او بالاصح
التخطيط لهجوم على سكه حديد للقرم لكن
الامن الفدرالي الروسي يقول بانه احبط هذه
المحاوله والقى على الشخص المتورط بهذه
العمليه تتحدث يتحدث جهاز الامن يقول بان
هذا الشخص له ارتباطات بالمخابرات
الاوكرانيه وكان يعمل بحسب التوصيف هنا
بانه كانوا يعملوا ج جاسوسا لجهاز
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه على مجموعه من
المستويات المستوى الاول في جمع المعلومات
المرتبطه بالاماكن العسكريه في شبه جزيره
القرم وتسليمها للمخابرات الاوكرانيه ربما
هذه هي الوسيله للحصول على معطيات ربما
بهدف الهجوم عليها النق النقطه الثانيه
والتي تبدو اكثر اهميه وهي التخطيط للهجوم
على سكه حديد بالمنطقه هذهه السكه هي
معروفه بالاستعمال العسكري ونقل المعدات
والذخيره العسكريه والعثور على عبوه
بلاستيكيه مصنعه من اجل استعمالها في هذا
الهجوم لكن تم احباط هذا الهجوم والقاء
القبض على هذا الشخص وبالتالي يمكن القول
بان هذه العمليه بناء على معطيات جهاز
الامن الفيدرالي الروسي بان هذ هذه
العمليه فشلت تم القاء القبض على الشخص
واحبطت هذهه العمليه لكن سهام بكل تاكيد
هذه العمليه لا يمكن فصلها عن طبيعه
المواجهات ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا وتعدد
الاساليب العسكريه التي يستعملها كل طرف
لاجل استهداف الطرف الاخر ربما هذا العمل
الاستخباراتي جمع المعلومات استهداف مواقع
بالداخل يعتبر استراتيجيه مهمه لضرب العمق
الروسي لكن بكل تاكيد على مستوى الجبهات
هناك نقاط متعدده الان ربما تقوم بها
القوات الاوكرانيه هنا نتحدث عن المسيرات
التي بدات تضرب الحدود الروسيه في منطقه
روسف نتحدث عن بريانسك نتحدث عن بغرد
وخاصه بريانسك منذ صباح هذا اليوم الى
الان ربما هناك العديد من المسيرات ثلاث
مسيرات تم ارسالها الى داخل هذه المنطقه
لكن تتحدث وزاره الدفاع عن اسقاط هذه
المسيرات احدى هذه المسيرات يبدو انها
سقطت بالقرب او على ب كيلومترات من احدى
القواعد العسكريه في رسف لكن دون ان تحدث
اي اصابات اذا ما حاولنا ان نفهم هذه
المسيرات وهذا الهجوم يمكن من خلاله عبد
القادر ان نفهم كذلك طبيعه الهجوم الذي
قام به الجانب الروسي وهو ضرب منطقه سومي
هذه المنطقه هناك حديث الان روسي على ان
هذه المنطقه الحدوديه او هذه المقاطعه
الحدوديه اصبحت تشكل نوعا ما خطرا على
الحدود الروسيه باعتبارها انها اصبحت
منطلقه لجميع المسيرات التي تضرب الحدود
الروسيه واكثر من ذلك منطلق ومستودع
للذخيره وكذلك للعمليات والمدفعيات التي
تستهدف هذه المناطق لذلك يمكن ان يفهم
لماذا استهدفت سومي وكذلك في بعض الاوقات
تستهدف خاركيف باشار تك للمسيرات وهنا
اذهب الى الياس كرام ايضا عن المسيرات
هذهه المره في سماء اوديسا بالاضافه الى
معطيات اخرى فيما يتعلق بالجانب الاوكراني
الياس بالفعل الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
بحسب ما اعلن عنه الجيش الاوكراني تمكنت
من اعتراض 26 مسيره روسيه كانت تتجه صوب
مقاطعه اوديسا وقد تمكنت هذه الدفاعات من
اسقاط 26 مسيره من اصل 20 حيث ان الاهداف
الروسيه في هذه المنطقه هي الموانئ
البحريه على البحر الاسود في اديسا وكذلك
في اسماعيل ورينيه على نهر الذنوب التي
تستخدمها السلطات الاوكرانيه كممر لنقل
الحبوب وبالتالي هذه الهجمات التي تستهدف
تلك الموانئ تستهدف المستودعات مستودعات
الحدو الحبوب والمنشات المتعلقه في تلك
الموانئ في محاوله لقطع الطريق على
اوكرانيا في هذا الممر الذي تسعى الى
احداثه في تلك المنطقه دا عن ذلك صافرات
الانذار دوت في عموم اوكرانيا منذ فجر هذا
اليوم وحتى ساعات الصباح حيث تعرضت العديد
من المقاطعات في اوكرانيا الى قصف صاروخي
ابرز الهجمات كانت في منطقه كريفيي شمال
خرسون في المناطق الجنوبيه لاوكرانيا حيث
سقط صاروخ في منطقه ماهوله مما ادى الى
مقتل شرطي واصابه 26 شخصا اخر على الاقل
بعضهم في حاله الخطر تم انتشالهم من بين
الانقاد وكذلك هو الحال في المقاطعه
الشماليه في سومي حيث سقط ايضا صاروخ في
مبنى مؤلف من طابقين وادى الى دمار شامل
فيه مما ادى الى جرح شخصين على الاقل
واصابه شخصين على الاقل وتضرر العديد من
المباني في هذا الحي الماهول كما تعرضت
مناطق دنيبرو وزبرو ايضا الى القصف بحسب
بحسب ما قالت المصادر المحليه الاوكرانيه
عدا عن ذلك القوات البريه الاوكرانيه تقول
بانها تواصل تحقيق النجاحات في التقدم صوب
المناطق الجنوبيه لزبار جيا في محورين
اساسيين المحور الجنوبي الشرقي لاقليم
دونباس عند اوجلا دار واجين وتقول بان
انها حققت ايضا انجازات حول قريتين مهمتين
هما نوفو دونيتسك ونوفو ماريسكي
باتجاه فولنا فاخا هذه المدينه المهمه على
محور ماريوبل التي تسعى القوات الاوكرانيه
الى تحقيق انتصار ووصولها والوصول اليها
وبالتالي قطع الطريق طريق الامدادات من
الدنباس الى مدينه مريول التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
وفول نفاخه هي ايضا نقطه هامه لتقاطع سكك
الحديد العسكريه التي تستخدمها القوات
الروسيه لنقل الامدادات الى منطقه خرسون
والى شبه جزيره القر الياس كرم من زبروجيا
ونورد من موسكو شكرا جزيلا
لكم